what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so continuing our discussions on DC
rebirth we pick up now with green arrow
and this is actually a one-shot called
sins of the mother now again this deals
a lot with a Miko and her character is
really well done and this particular
story I actually really really like what
Benjamin Percy's doing with her because
he's really fleshing her out in a lot of
different ways now again at the end of
the life and death of Oliver Queen we
learned that amico was actually a double
agent that were previously it appeared
as though she was working against Oliver
Queen on behalf of her mother that it
actually turned out but she had
basically been working from the shadows
to save Oliver Queen to keep him alive
in the face of almost guaranteed death
the problem with this was that in this
final battle which of course you can
find that video down in the description
but in this final battle she was
effectively tranquilized by her mother
and then taken away before Oliver Queen
could step mana so this essentially
continues her story now with her mother
taking her away of course you know she
really chastises amico in a lot of
different ways for what she considers to
be her recklessness or for what she
considers to be her foolishness but we
also learned that Amigos mother was a
double agent as well and she'd been
working for another party aside from
those as she was initially working with
with regards to the life and death of
Oliver Queen and so again we follow a
miko when she gives us this kind of
play-by-play in a lot of ways of her
early life when she first encountered
Oliver Queen because remember she was
introduced as the sort of illegitimate
daughter of Robert Queen and since that
she is the you know half-sister of
Oliver um but she's not a direct
biological sister in the sense that
she's not the direct child of both of
Oliver Queen's parents instead she's
really just the child of an affair but
because of this when she eventually you
know linked up basically with Oliver
there was a lot of debate going on back
and forth a lot of argument because I
didn't really see eye to eye and the
reason behind this is because a Miko's
backstory is very similar to damian
wayne in the sense that damian wayne was
basically brought to Batman once he was
in his in his preteens but by that point
in his life he was already a very
accomplished assassin as he'd been
trained by Talia al Ghul and the League
of Assassins
so because of that he was very difficult
to kind of turn around to reel back in
to bring back to technology and as
opposed to being this extremely violent
and dangerous child
Emiko is is nowhere near as Extreme as
Damian Wayne was but she is someone that
spent a lot of her early days under the
tutelage of an assassin guilt and so
because of that she was taught to be an
assassin now this was also beneficial
for Oliver Queen in the sense that when
she came on board he didn't really have
to train her in terms of you know
stealth and guile and espionage
subterfuge charity knew all that stuff
instead it was really him just trying to
get to grips with who she was as a
person and trying to work with her in
terms of the two of them forming a a
brother and sister relationship now one
of the other funny things about this is
she talks about her relation with Oliver
Queen in the sense that he was trying to
introduce her to a very normal life and
this or at least as normal as Oliver
Queen gets and she even goes as far as
to say that he made her watch movies
play board games you know movies like
The Goonies Hoosiers and and Raiders of
the Lost Ark now in my mind I have a
hard time grasping a scenario where
anyone would be forced to watch Raiders
in the Lost Ark I guess one of the best
movies ever made like I want to know if
you've ever seen Raiders of the Lost Ark
post a comment I want to know because
Raiders of the Lost Ark is one of the
best movies ever made like Indiana Jones
is one of the best movie series ever
made in Raiders of the Lost Ark was
absolutely amazing I loved it I loved
Raiders of the Lost Ark but the fact
remains here that that Oliver really
does what he can to kind of reintegrate
her back into normal society but she
also works as you know not really uh not
really like speedy I guess not really as
speedy or as arsenal but effectively as
a sidekick of his and so were the two of
them working together the two of them
effectively being a team what we also
learned is there's a lot been a lot
going on in Seattle and what I mean is
there have been a rash of robberies that
have been committed by young people for
reasons that don't seem to be known in
the sense that there's a kid that
basically tried to carjack a woman you
know there's a kid that was racing off
on a motorcycle a kid whose heart
effectively just stopped
you know while he was in police custody
no one really knew why but for a Miko
because of the fact that she is so
distant from normal society instead of
you know trying to live a normal life
the way that Oliver instructed her to is
she actually turned her attention to
trying to figure out this mystery you
know what's going on here and so what
did she actually infiltrated a group of
elite citizens or I guess will elite
students in her school a lot of the kids
who were involved in a lot of different
things you know sports music community
service so on and so forth but all of
them shared one unique trait which was
this watch or at least it seemed like a
band of sorts that had the same symbol
now as she follows them we actually find
out that this symbol belongs to the
clock King now is something that I want
to point out here is that this is not
William tockman this is not the original
clock King that most everybody is
familiar with that version of the clock
King is alive but this is a new one
operating with a different agenda we'll
actually find out a little more about
him as we go on but Jimmy back to the
modern day we actually find out that the
mother of amico was working effectively
for the Yakuza based out of Tokyo Japan
now this is something that's really cool
with regards to what Benjamin Percy
writes I wouldn't go as far as to say
the Benjamin Percy is like an expert on
the different gangs of the world but I
will go as far as to say that his his
indication here of the who'sa actually
seems to be pretty accurate those thing
eyes who don't know the Yakuza are
really like one of the most prominent
gangs I think there are about a hundred
to thousand members worldwide but
they're one of the most prominent gangs
based out of Asia but they operate
around the world they're really like one
of these you know transnational
organizations as part of the criminal
underworld but they're also very rooted
in Japanese traditional kind of this
amalgamation between new Japanese
beliefs and old Japanese beliefs you
know for example their ranking system
their hierarchy is very indicative of
new Japanese beliefs so you have like a
president you know and the chain of
command kind of goes down from there but
they're very traditional in terms of
Honor in the sense that from eCos mother
tells her is that because of the fact
that her father was previously part of
the of the Cuza and had failed that his
shame became her shame because she bore
the same blood as her father the blood
that was passed down to a miko and so
it's really one of these things where
it's not you know a physical kind of
shame in the sense that you know she is
her father's daughter and so she will
bear the shame of her father and
everyone in her family's line will bear
that shame as well and so because of
that Emiko is basically someone who's
looked at as you know by the Yakuza as
someone that either needs to be
eliminated or at the very least needs to
be brought before them in order for a
Miko's mother to make penance for her
perceived shame as well as amico being
someone that can work on the
for the Yakuza now in truth this is
really you know behind the scenes in
terms of the bigger picture I would say
this is really just an instance where
the Yakuza just want a miko to work for
them because remember she's one of the
foremost assassins and that's really one
of the cool things about DC Comics
that's what I like about Benjamin
Percy's writing the DC is markedly
different from Marvel Comics when it
comes to the overall world this is
something I actually didn't realize
until I jumped into the new 52 well a DC
very real world in terms of how things
exist in Marvel Comics you don't really
have the Yakuza
they're not really like a main force I
mean they exist they're an organization
that's there but Marvel focuses more on
fictional organizations so like advanced
idea mechanics Hydra different things
like that you know the the Friends of
humanity which was an organization that
existed in the 80s I'm sorry and Marvel
comics in the 90s or the 80s I think I
came in roughed up my head but you know
they're they have all these different
fictional organizations that exist out
there
DC goes very real world and it creates a
lot of relatability here but the problem
here for amiko is that she spent so much
time free of control with regards to
being lorded over by other organizations
that she doesn't see herself as a tool
that can be used by someone else instead
she sees herself as a free woman you
know she's like I fight my own Wars I
operate by my own agenda and I will not
be taken under the tutelage of someone
that I don't want to be trained by and
forced to do things that I don't want to
do and so she effectively turns against
her mom and seems to essentially run
away and so for here we jump back to
Seattle with a clock King and this is
where we learned there's a lot more
going on here in the sense that you know
these kids are coming out of the clock
Kings Building you know they seem really
really amped up they seem really excited
but the clock King began speaking with
amiko and when she offers you know to
pay for for information or when she
offers to try to attain something you
know ultimately he says you know try
this watch on you know try this watch on
it'll help you out and effectively it
seems to have some kind of a catch to it
now again what kind of you know jump
back to this but we we basically pick up
in the current day with a Miko in Tokyo
now because of the fact that amiko is or
I guess Neil Miko's mother's more or
less being shanghaied into forcing and
Miko to become part of the yakuza amigos
responses will tha let's just take out
the Yakuza let's take out their their
crime boss you know sort of send a
message that they don't mess with us now
the Yakuza is very much like Hydra from
Marvel Comics in the sense that if the
crime boss is taken out another guy will
take his place and amigos not really
looking to eliminate
the entirety of the Yakuza what she's
looking to do is to prove a point to say
you got I don't care what you guys do
but you don't come after me and you
don't come after the people that I care
about you leave us alone and so this is
the the message she intends to send out
the issue with this is that she
basically wanders into this this karaoke
nightclub as essentially a front for the
you cruise and this is really this is
why I say Benjamin person does a great
job with this because that's usually how
it works I mean this is effectively you
know like like I'm a Jinnah a haven for
money laundering for criminals of the
world you know it's a very seedy
organization a very seedy place but when
she gets in there she gets up on stage
and basically goes against one of the
guys who's fighting and the reason why
she does this is because if she
successfully beats this guy who seems to
be someone that people look at as one of
the most formidable fighters there then
it means that the head of the Yakuza
will take notice of her it means they'll
realize who she is now what this will
probably do is grant her an audience and
then she would say okay fine I'll take
this as an opportunity to kill the main
boss to kill the top guy of the Yakuza
and so things go almost exactly as she
plans in the sense that she jumps into
the fight and immediately starts
engaging in a battle with him now from
here we switched back again to the Past
with regards to Seattle and the clock
king and of course we have Oliver Queen
and amico going against these kids you
know that she was trailing before they
were part of her school that we're
knocking over a bank that were
constantly keeping themselves wound up
there were always doing something in
order to keep their energy up now the
reason for this is revealed when she
begins to at least it seems like a Miko
staking out and when she travels at the
clock King we learned that this guy is
actually a drug dealer now again this is
a market difference from tockman this is
Amaro a market difference from the clock
King as we originally knew him in the
sense that this new guy is effectively
peddling a drug that requires people to
constantly solicit the services now the
reason for that is because when they put
on the watch it begins pumping a hyper
stimulant into their body and if they do
not go back to the clock King and
acquire more hyper stimulant their
bodies will effectively shut down and so
this is really really interesting
because this shows us that not all the
villains that exist out there in DC
Comics are out there in your face you
know the world is aware of them
sometimes it's just one guy operating
out of a nondescript store who's
effectively tricking the entire
community into religious becoming you
know drug addicts
more or less is really the best way to
put it here but I kind of like what's
going on with this you know what
Benjamin Percy and this this clock King
guy I like the direction this is going
and I really love to see you know we're
the future of this holds but what we
also have is what what at least what
seems like amico getting past this but
then eventually we find out that Oliver
Queen also has one of these watches now
whether or not Oliver Queen took the
watch of umeko it's something that we
don't know yet all we know is that he
has a watch on his wrist and so there
may be that it's somewhere along the
line he you know fell into business with
the clock King and he believes he's
operating secretly the two of them just
haven't really synched up with regards
to their just their discovery of who the
clock king is and what he's about or it
may just be that he just took it from
amiko in order to relieve her of her
burden now that that seems most likely
to be the case because of the fact that
it is Oliver Queen
but again you know with regard to this
comic this looked very much ambiguous
because we don't see the wrist of a miko
so we don't know if that's the case it's
not one of the biggest things in the
world but I like this because it's
basically setting the seeds for future
stories is setting the seeds for small
things and that's why I like a lot you
know in comics in general that's why I
like you know good storytelling because
it'd be very easy for a of a
person to take the road and to say and
here are things that happen and that
story's over and here's more things that
happen and that story's over it'd be
very easy for him to you know to begin
the story and in the story within a
handful of issues as opposed to creating
you know these threads that branch out
into other comics you know maybe you you
see some discussion at the beginning of
one kind of book issue but then you
don't learn anything about it until five
six seven eight issues down the line and
then suddenly it becomes important I
really like that because it keeps you
reading it keeps you guessing it keeps
you wondering what's going to happen
next in the story it's just kind of my
two cents there's one of the reasons why
I love the Green Arrow writing so far
it's it's absolutely absolutely
beautiful the way it's done but again
you know jumping back to the present day
in Tokyo of course the Miko is able to
easily subdue this guy you know subdue
this fighter and in doing so she's
granted an audience with the Yakuza but
instead of killing her they actually
address her as a Miko as a queen and
they say it's time for us to basically
discuss your future most likely a future
as part of the Yakuza but with that
being said again this is really just a
one shot you know this is just kind of
benjamin percy saying hey you know we're
going to be building on things later on
but this this one shot and the next one
which is killing time i think are just
designed to sort of build things up and
give us some perspective and again lay
the groundwork for future stuff in the
green arrow mythos but it because we're
new here the comments explained make
sure you hit the subscribe button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video drop a like and leave
a comment down below let me know what
you guys think about this so far
now we'll catch you all later peace
[Music]